salvo les facs dos une messe joué pour
la première fois dans le mur de la
chapelle royale depuis cinq siècles
l'oeuvre illustre le voeu de louis xiii
en 1638 leroy consacre le royaume de
france à la vierge marie louis xiii fils
d'henri iv et père de louis xiv qui a
voué la france à la vierge marie
du jour où il a appris que anne
d'autriche était enceinte d'un futur
dauphin qui allait être louis dieudonné
louis xiv
donc il a dédié la france à la vierge en
reconnaissance le centre de musique
baroque de versailles fait revivre ce
chef-d'oeuvre le concert s'inscrit dans
la programmation des jeudis musicaux
un rendez vous pour faire découvrir le
travail des pages et des chantres de la
maîtrise
j'aime beaucoup le fait de rechanter les
mêmes champs qui il ya très longtemps
ont été donnés ici dans cette si belle
chapelle par rapport à la musique
d'aujourd'hui c'est une musique très
religieuse très très solennelle
l'auditeur qui vient ici pour la
première fois nous l'invitons vraiment à
voile à voyager dans l'histoire c'est
une façon un peu de faire revivre toutes
ces voix lasse ses murs en t2 tous les
je dirais tous les fantômes des chantres
et des des pages prochain voyage la
pastorale sur la naissance de
jésus-christ de marc antoine charpentier
le 24 novembre
une plongée au coeur du royaume de
france des xviie et xviiie siècles